I want to ask you something that's
really important I think to a lot of the
uh public that has to do with the
housing crisis and the middle class kind
of just disintegrating what's your plan
for that if you're in
office you know I have an extensive plan
for um how to get this generation of
kids into housing and you know I'm this
is one of my principal preoccupations
that I have seven kids and uh and one of
them the eldest who's 39 is in house but
the other the six younger ones between
20 and you know and
30 none of them has any prayer of
getting into a home and the housing
prices have gone up um by from
$215,000 to two years ago to 400,000
today the interest rates have gone up
from 3% to almost 8% which means my kids
are paying 10 or 11% and they're
competing against Black Rock stage and
and it's company black Black Rock
doesn't actually buy single family homes
but these giant
beths Blackstone Black Rock State Street
Vanguard Fidelity are are now buying
single family they own you can't
dismantle them no you can't but there's
things that you can do and I I I'm happy
to talk about that they own 89% of the
S&P 500 okay and now they're trying to
buy all of our farmland and they're
trying to buy um all of our uh our
single family homes what can you do is
that considered a monopoly is that like
a monopoly no it it in
some black rock is not a monopoly but it
has companies within certain sectors
that are operating monopolistically and
in those cases I will bring Sherman
Antitrust Act actions against them um
I'll do the on the longer term I'll do
I'll fix the IRS which I need the Senate
and House to do and I'll um and I'll I
I'm gonna I'm gonna put I'm going to
offer a
law that will penalize large companies
large investment firms from owning
multiple units of single family housing
so it will no longer be profitable and
that will release a tremendous amount of
housing back into the marketplace so our
kid right now our kids are competing
against black black Rock's bankbook so
you know my kid has a crappy credit
rating what I'm going to do is I'm going
to issue a new class immediately a new
class of t- Bill treasury bills at 3%
interest to people who are buying single
family homes particularly young people
and teachers and I'm going to um and and
I'm going to fund that by issuing these
treasury bill I'm going to issue
mortgages at 3% I'm going to fund that
with treasury bills that are are 3%
treasury
bills but they are taxfree so the the
company will beun funded by the market
and you know if you have a rich
Uncle um who will co-sign your mortgage
you can get a much better rate because
the bank is basing their interest rate
not on your lousy credit
rating but on your uncle's fantastic
credit rating and I'm going to give
everybody a rich Uncle all these young
people which is Uncle Sam which is going
to guarantee your mortgage so allow you
to get that 3% rate and if you default
on it you know we will inherit the
federal government will har this is how
Freddy M Fanny May operated and they now
have $110 billion Surplus from the homes
that they
reclaimed my uncle did a very very
similar um uh legislation in uh in
1961 and this week I was in Orlando or
in Tampa um visiting one of the
apartment units there's I think there's
183 apartment units the the the rent for
those units about $250 a
month I was at 3% interest it was one of
the you know and I'm going to do that I
mean my primary objective other than
ending the forever
Wars and ending the chronic disease
epidemic is to get this generation of
kids into
houses
I